we're speaking today with Tom Perez the
secretary of labor for in the United
States Department of Labor so thank you
mr. secretary for joining us maybe you
could talk a little bit about what's
changed since you and I entered the
labor force a number of years ago I'm
thinking about a good friend of mine
whose dad graduated high school went to
work at Bethlehem Steel and worked there
for 42 years and as we fast-forward to
today it is much less frequent to see
someone at a job for 30 40 years like
our parents generation and once again
you you look in the world of
manufacturing just to take one example
the jobs of today are quite different
from the jobs of yesterday and frankly
in many cases a high school degree
simply won't suffice and so my parents
always taught me education is the great
equalizer it's what made America a
superpower this commitment to free
public elementary and secondary
education and today we need to keep that
investment maybe we could focus on some
of the current challenges and
opportunities we're coming out of this
Great Recession the worst since the
Great Depression the economy has been
growing but not everyone is sharing
equally and the benefits of of the
growth what accounts for where we are
today well it's always important to look
at where we were where we are and where
we need to go the rising tide of
progress in the late 90s that we saw
lifted more boats today that rising tide
isn't lifting as many boats as it needs
to we need to make sure that everybody
has that chance and that one of the
biggest challenges in this context is
addressing the issue of stubbornly
stagnant wages and and that's not simply
a phenomenon of the Great Recession
for decades productivity growth and real
wage growth rose hand in hand and then
starting around 1980 that began to
change and we see productivity increases
of over 90 percent and real wage growth
of 2 or 3 percent and that's unfair
workers are our have helped bake the pie
of prosperity but their sweat equity
hasn't translated into financial equity
for them and so too many people haven't
gotten a raise in years too many people
are working two or three jobs one of the
best family values is the value of time
spent with your family and folks just
don't have enough time to do that we
could talk a little bit perhaps about
how we can get wages and high quality
jobs moving in the right direction and I
know you are an ardent advocate for the
administration for the country about the
importance of skills and skill
development wonder if you could say what
your thoughts are on what workers might
do and what kind of opportunities we
need to provide for workers to keep
those skills current so that people can
adapt over time you look at the data and
the education dividend is undeniable the
more education you have the greater the
chances are that you can punch your
ticket to the middle class and then stay
there it's important to recognize that
there are multiple educational pathways
to the middle class
some people graduate high school and go
to college but other people especially
when I was growing up a buffalo a lot of
folks went through the apprenticeship
route and that route if you go to places
like Germany it has equal stature with
the four-year route and here in America
we devalued that over the course of
recent decades and that's why this
president and and and we at the
Department of Labor are trying to change
that and I've met so many folks who have
completed apprenticeship programs
whether it's the traditional skilled
trades whether it's IT whether it's in
the health sectors these are these are
alternative pathways to higher ed and
many of these folks who complete
apprenticeships then get an associate's
degree at Community College and then go
to a four-year college so it's important
as people think about that pathway to
upskilling to recognize that there are
multiple entry points and they all lead
to core competencies that enable you to
compete and thrive not only in today's
economy but in tomorrow's economy well I
think your work on apprenticeships it's
so important because the evidence is so
clear on how that well they pay off for
every dollar we invest in apprenticeship
the return is something like $27 that's
a I wish every investment we made had
that kind of return you know one of the
concepts that we use in this course is
the terms social contract and you've
been an articulate proponent of a strong
voice for the American workforce wonder
if you could speak a bit about the role
of voice in our economy and what it
means to workers and what it means to
our society it's not a coincidence in my
mind that the periods in our nation's
history in the 20th century for instance
where you had decade after decade of
real wage growth didn't just coincide
but coexisted with a period of time
where workers had a collective voice
where you had much higher union density
where people could advocate America's
greatest generation who fought in World
War two millions of them came home and
what did they do they they worked
collectively once again in the workplace
and to fight for fair wages and and what
we I think have lost today is is too
many folks have bought into this false
choice you either take care of your
shareholder or you take care of your
worker but you can't do both that's it I
categorically reject that and it is
indeed a false choice you look at places
like the Ford Motor Company an
existential crisis in the great
recession and what happened the UAW and
Ford got together around a plan of
shared sacrifice leading to shared
prosperity so I I visited a plant in
Louisville Kentucky that makes the Ford
Escape and in 2007 they were down to
about 700 workers they weren't sure if
they were gonna shutter the plant
entirely and and as a result of that
cooperation you see shared sacrifice
leading to shared prosperity today
they're 4,400 employees and growing and
that doesn't include the supply chain so
when workers have
America succeeds there are many ways to
give voice to workers unions are
certainly one way there are also a
number of nonprofits that are working
with taxi cab drivers and home health
workers and fast-food workers nonprofits
that are very agile and and they're
really standing up for low-wage workers
trying to give voice there are a lot of
headwinds in this issue there aren't
courts right now that are hostile to
efforts to organize there's hostile
state legislators right now that are
making it hard for public sector workers
to move forward
there are well-heeled multi-billionaires
who are spending a lot of money trying
to muzzle voice but these forces existed
100 years ago we've defeated these
before the arc of the moral universe has
always bent toward justice and toward
those who seek to expand opportunity but
it doesn't Bend on its own I'm wondering
if you would like to conclude with your
own advice for the next generation with
the force first of all I think education
is the great equalizer so you want to
make sure that you have the skills to
compete today and tomorrow secondly you
need to find your passion happiest is
the person whose job is his or her hobby
because then you never have to work a
day in your life third you need to
reject these false choices of those who
suggest that if you burn out your
neighbor's candle that will make your
candle shine brighter that's never been
who we are as a nation we've always been
a community recognizing that we all
succeed only when we all succeed we we
rise and fall on the strength of our
middle class and the strength of our
ladders of opportunity to the middle
class and and so I want everyone all
your students to make sure they
understand that opportunities abound and
low wages and no benefits are a choice
that companies make not a necessity born
out of globalization or technology
advances these are choices and you need
to make that choice as a student to get
involved and to exert leadership well a
very very powerful statement mr.
secretary thank you for all you do and
for all everyone here at the Department
of Labor does for the current generation
workforce and for all of those to come
on time take care thanks again
you